because it on niether yeah they have to
be hiding because we are in a
dictatorship so we have to take care of
him did they fail it endanger Careca
temple Edo a secret location and the
first interview with British television
from Juan Guido he may be called interim
president but he is basically on the run
from the security services here
despite the swirl of accusations of
denial from both sides he dismissed a
meeting with Nicolas Maduro as a waste
of time he says he believes that Maduro
would do anything to keep in power
there's no doubt about it that's almost
a guarantee from a regime with so many
social and political and economic
demands when they don't have ways to
solve these problems they use violence
they've killed 40 young people and that
hurts a lot 700 people detained but that
will not stop the social and political
pressure and we can enforce the majority
we have as a parliament and as the
president in charge of Venezuela the
opposition is organizing more protests
against Maduro they usually turn violent
we witnessed it on the streets of
Caracas white Oh says the violence will
only come from the government side but
he expects it the protests that have
taken place often end violently more are
due do you expect them to be violent as
well the world has seen this that we are
doing this peacefully why are they doing
this
because they want to instill fear in the
people but what we have here in
Venezuela is hope and despite those
risks we are going to keep ourselves on
the streets
you send out a clear message that
changes will happen but that the
international community will be vital to
make those changes before then it's all
about pressure in the short term we have
to keep the people on the streets
we'll keep the demonstrations going we
will continue to get support from the
world not only Europe for example the
ultimatum given to Maduro the 35 year
old has galvanized the opposition here
and his regular public appearances have
kept the momentum but it does come at a
personal risk you are obviously in a lot
of danger this is a regime that has a
history of dealing with people often
violently or at least in prison how do
you feel about that and and and and you
fear for your family as well there have
been threats on my life and they're not
recent my generation in Venezuela grew
up in dictatorship and we've had to deal
with losing friends to protest see them
imprisoned or see them being tortured
that's the reality what we fear is this
carries on why does external support is
certainly growing but it's the internal
support and the support of the military
that he really needs that is yet to
translate into actuality rounds of Sky
News correct